[موسيقى]
تشتهر محافظه جنوب الشرقيه بحصونها
وقلاعها ومواقعها الاثريه هنا في ولايه
صور مركزه هذه المحافظه يعد حصن سنسله من
اهم وابرز المواقع التاريخيه والسياحيه في
هذه الولايه
[موسيقى]
هذا الحصن افتتح عام 1650 تم بناءه بعد
طرد البرتغاليين من سلطنه عمان يتميز
بموقعه المطل على ولايه الصور ويضم الحصن
عده مرافق ابرزها غرفه الشيخ والمسجد
ومدرسته لتحفيظ القران بالاضافه الى اربعه
ابراج ثلاثه منها ابراج حربيه والبرج
الغربي الرابع للمراقبه
[موسيقى]
البلد هنا جميل
للغايه ثم انتقلنا الى ولايه صور ومررنا
بوادي شاب انه مكان مدهش ومبدع
[موسيقى]
مناره العيد هي الاخرى احدى اهم المعالم
السياحيه في ولايه الصور على مدخل جسر خور
البطح هذه المناره بناها البرتغاليون
وتعتبر من اقدم المنارات البحريه في
السلطنه وقد كانت في الاساسي برج حمايه
تحولت في مباعد الى مناره استخدمت لتوجيه
السفن التقليديه
عمان والبلاد تملك طبيعه خلابه خاصه في
الاوديه القريبه من الولايه زرنا ايضا
مصنع السفن هنا في صور كان ما كان رائعا
ولايه صور تعتبروا ايضا واحده من اقدم
الموانئ البحريه في العالم ولها دور حيوي
في التبادلات التجاريه بين سلطنه عمان
وشرقيه افريقيا والهند والبصره قديما عبر
مينائها الذي كان محطه استيراد وتصدير
لمختلف البضائع عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
ولايه الصور العربيه